so there's the worst case for you the
other lenders that didn't pass have got
a couple of weeks to put together a plan
and then implement it in the next nine
months or somehow plug those capital
holes
time now to pull apart those test
results with our expert from the german
institute for economic research cast in
bernard thank you very much for coming
in first of all
let's start with the tests themselves
though the criteria tough enough
tougher than in in the test that they uh
performed before
but not i wouldn't say that they were
too tough
would you go as far as saying or calling
them a farce because some people have
they've they've called them a fast
they've said that they deeply understate
the risk of deflation they also deeply
understate the debt leverage that could
be used in a crisis
um i wouldn't go so far so far so but i
would say that that they only actually
modeled a scenario of a mild recession
and they actually neglected a lot of
risk like the deflationary risks and um
but it's always the problem when you
have scenario analysis that you have to
you cannot test for all
scenarios but when you say mild
recession
what are we going into at the moment in
the block i think we have a
major research reception yeah for
example in the stress test they assume
fall of gdp by 1.6
but we observed in the last
few years
a
drop in gdp which was much bigger
because let me point out the ecb's
argument was that deflation was not
included in this test
because deflation's not going to happen
and i mean the eurozone at least the
periphery is already in deflation isn't
it
yes but the ecb is of course uh looking
on at the average at the european
average inflation ratio and there we are
not yet in deflation although we see
there's some risk but
we are not in a deflation yet and what
are the biggest risks that have resulted
from this test
the bigger bigger the biggest risks that
we have to look out for or worry about
so we have to worry of course about the
huge
amount of non-performing loans that the
ecb discovered on the bank balance
sheets
um
that
a couple of banks or
25 banks were
originally last year were
under-capitalized
that's of course
a risk that we have to take seriously
okay so the test has achieved something
it's pointed out things that the lenders
need to do they need to bolster their
capital reserves but now that a lot of
them have enough buffer there
why are they they not lending to
businesses that actually need that
credit
um
so the the problem is do we have a
credit supply problem or credit demand
problem and i would say clearly it's
both so in the crisis countries um but
even if the
the the banks have the ability to give
credit to the corporate sector in the
crisis countries they are maybe not
willing because the economic situation
is too weak
default risks are too high
and
so to speak i would say that the stress
test is not necessarily the solution to
boost uh credit growth what does that do
to trust trust in the banks trust in the
block
um i would say that the stress test was
important to um
to to to improve credibility and trust
in the markets but we should necessarily
still be careful
a couple of years ago everybody said the
banking sector is resilient and a couple
of months later we were in the deepest
banking crisis we have ever seen and
just very briefly we heard about the
austrian lender winding up is that the
only option if the bank can't find
enough capital if it can't uh merge or
take on state help
yes
so basically um if that is the only
option then um and one of the only other
ones is taking on state help um that
involves the taxpayer again the taxpayer
is roped in again and i thought that
that's what we were trying to avoid in
all of this yes and that's
where we currently work on that we try
to establish a single resolution
mechanism in on the european level that
to avoid
exactly that that the taxpayer always
has to step in and not the creditors or
the debt holders okay well we'll see if
we can achieve that katherine bernhardt
thank you very much for the insight